c'est c'est monique mon nom je l'avoué
la rue de richelieu
vous n'êtes pas du tout dans le coup on
était à opéra ici et madame n'ont ni
tard madame royal ah non écoutez on
était au coeur je connais bien sûr
plaisantez ou quoi
nota palais royal ici oui des cheveux
longs est bien au coeur a quand même si
monsieur justement vous êtes un non
voyant et si vous vous êtes trompés mais
un type ans a traversé pendant
vous aider à traverser pour vous avez ou
là vous allez droitement alors fait je
veux dire vous traversiez
bâtons et bouteilles d'homosexuels
j'ai trois mois sexuelle nous venons
vous voulez gérer la matinée vous me
jurez ce que je viens traverser mais
j'avais des hommes avec moi elle est
bonne oui alors on est là on la touche
et ça peut aller segments sont prenants
mutuelle
michel a des bonnes et en travers je lui
propose de l'aider à travers son travail
bon bien échangiste d'échangistes bon
voilà c'est moi je traverse pour un
montage michel c'est pas possible je
suis folle et non eux le louvre et les
ouds volet louvel est là mais j'ai rien
à faire au louvre et par vous alors là
c'est les verts font la rue par là vous
allez allez c'est vraiment beau faire
plaisir ce que c'est pas du tout ma
direction voilà
mais je vais un opéra j'y suis c'est bon
et non des 37 palais royal annonce aucun
jeu 4 à 6 ans pour le changement
présentait l'état palais royal musée du
palais royal musée du louvre à cheval on
l'a vu encore et c'est un chasseur
d'épaves d'alors chercheurs il ya une
expression
versez la pâte
d'accord vous voulez où je sache je vois
rien à la météo aux toilettes et on l'a
vu donner des mois alors
je sais pas vous mais autrement
embrouilles et là je vous demandez rien
comme sauter dessus
vous commencez à me faire chier
maintenant je vous aider à traverser
parce qu'on sait jamais venu avait cédé
brûlant et cannes avec passion c'est
toujours pareil alors vous avez vous
aider voilà voilà
faites attention à vos seins les
imprimés la voix venues passer vers un
monde digne caen sait vers où nous dit
quand le feu est vert
tiens ne voulait pas versés à wall
street le hockey
le ou vers le vent joue au hockey ou
opera
maintenant mais trop lourd
ok c'est rouge la grande affiche pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il mettait un peu
de bleu